[Music]
in entitled Influenster news submitted
by the night's king and Instagram
influencer whose page got deleted sighs
felt like who is this girl
this video she's like I'm not a nine to
fiver okay I move to LA you haven't seen
this yeah tell the news this is [ __ ]
good don't let your grin or something
right well not you alright not too low
you still have a hundred thousand
followers all right well no so her thing
up put back up but then they deleted it
again but then now it's back up I don't
know what the [ __ ]
so razzled right now her Instagram so
she made - oh no it's deleted again so I
can't even tell you that's so crazy
but just last night when I was looking
at it it was still up but now it's not
but when I saw it last night I think it
was I got 120 something thousand and
then the other one was I got 19,000 what
did she do would it get deleted for her
so she basically is an influencer does
that mean my quotes is she is she came
out here to be an impression in her life
so she's like your textbook wannabe but
what are you trying to influence a
fashion just just just a grammar like a
persona yeah yeah we have to be there
hot or talented no I mean like there's
the girl version of prank invasion right
like the girls that just get into I am
what's her stick though yeah yeah yeah
so so she see she's doing she's known
for doing stunts like like Jake Paul
like female Jake Paul not stunts as in
like challenges like controversy long
video saying I am a racist yeah I think
she started saying like this girl she
can't like no because she's black
yeah things like that
but then for Instagram it's more like a
whole Instagram it is yeah actually I
pulled it so you know I said that she
she has to Instagram accounts the other
one the 19k it says page not found
anymore but the one that she has now
dude what if she's 129 what if she's
disabling in herself she's she's at
129,000
so yeah it's like her page like she just
I wish he was here he knows all the
details on this he was telling me about
it and I only remember some of the
details but he's like just like nothing
well you didn't say get you were having
jokes win it so I thought you didn't
have any more information I have more
information I want to show you guys the
video Tim sorry Tim I thought you were
done continue I'm sorry okay
so let me play the video I have more
juicy information people tried to hit on
me report me I've literally tried to be
a [ __ ] better person I want to say to
everybody that's been reporting me they
twice because you're ruining my life and
I know people like to see me and be like
that 90% the people that were Hina 5 to
not be like that
it's [ __ ] hard to get to work I
forgot to get take it from me as the
worst but you feel like in the world way
I was a [ __ ] prostitute for godsake
day I don't even do that [ __ ] anymore
because I make all of my money online I
have no skills
I'm 20 [ __ ] thousand dollars is that
from school from college so I can't even
go to college if I [ __ ] wanted to so
stop [ __ ] reporting me on
[ __ ] Instagram the last thing I
want to do is be a [ __ ] homeless
prostitute the [ __ ] Street doing that
what it's just stop but you try to run
my life all the [ __ ]
I cited trolls out there I have no
skills yeah so apparently it seems like
she comes from like her family has money
so she's like I don't I don't have any
money and she why she prostituting who
knows that she know people that came
from hella money but like therapure use
the money to control them so they tried
it like rebel against their parents and
then they're like poor but they don't
know how to be a poor person like they
don't know how to get a job or any of
that because they grew up so entitled so
they're like like I know this one girl
she was crying because she thought she
might have to get a job and like because
her parents cut her off and and like she
had never got a job or Pitt is she's
like I might have to work at Cheesecake
Factory and at that point I had I had
been a waitress for like ten years and
I'm like they wouldn't hire you you have
to have a lot of experience I know
things on the menu yeah you could pass a
lot of tests to be able to be hired at
Cheesecake Factory if you even make it
past interviews and she had never yeah
she was like crying about it but you
know people get broken Bernie - that's
why I like the story [ __ ] the reason her
Instagram got deleted was because um
some like like not for CH it was a 4chan
or some like some group found her
profile and they just kept reporting all
over pictures well it seems to be like
it just she just has a lot of people
that hate her because of the things from
before the past group because they
didn't mention that in any of the
articles that are read but it just seems
like there's just a lot of people that
already just don't like her period by
the way she's 21 really young so yeah
they just kept reporting her page over
and over again and then it got deleted
but then histogram said that it was a
mistake that they deleted it and that's
why now it's back I don't know she
pulled some stuff forgot what it was but
it's hard to get kicked off Instagram I
don't know if it's that hard cuz Isaac's
page got deleted too but he violated a
rule you're not supposed to be under a
certain age and have an Instagram
there's a lot of people that do have
yeah but that's still against the rule I
know that's why I'm like that psych he
doesn't have one so but like - if you
don't violate clear violation
which is like hate speech or like
whatever or nudity I have friends who
have women pictures
yes who she posts [ __ ] tutorials on
her story bull she's constantly posting
like a little bit of her nipples covered
up and she's like saying swipe up go to
her because our patron has full nudity
so does she do it she never gets taken
out oh yeah she get doctors she makes a
lot of money yeah with her nude she gets
paid to like eat a bunch of my things
like people paid to watch her eat too
much food but our knuckles in the shop
so she's like nude just eating a lot of
patreon you should start the food this
high oh my god I gotta do this that's
what she's successful good then I'm
never gonna finish this I'm gonna cup to
hear like here's also full tune in next
week where I try again they're like Oh
Jill I'm not [ __ ] suckered again it's
like a [ __ ] Pokemon where it's like
tune in next week it's like what the
teasing don't take my idea I was about
to do I'm talking to them don't don't
throw it away I don't have any talents
or anything so don't take my only thing
away I don't have any boobs so I can't
do that no I'm talking to the camera not
you I was pointing to them oh I don't
get to watch this video but you can't
reply real-time yeah and I question
salts are followers too because like
most of people's falling are nine to
fivers yeah she's like I wanna be like
you guys I don't
that's - she's like I don't want it be a
90 percenter what does the other temper
centers the homeless people no no the
10% isn't elite like she moved to LA to
be the Union 1% the winners it is I
don't know what the [ __ ] she's talking
about because la is a is a city full of
nine-to-fivers yeah what do you think we
have so much damn traffic
nine-to-fivers with side hustles though
you're like all trying to not be at
night for the Niner Niners yeah hate
people that are keep moving here to try
to be man stop trying to be famous man
yeah you guys are adding so much traffic
and [ __ ] so you've had this rule he's
like if you don't book something in a
year you have to leave because like it
is a entertainment city right so I do
have a lot of people coming in that are
you know doing work great but if you're
still been waiting tables and you still
haven't booked anything in the last 10
years go back to where the [ __ ] you came
from that is like 50,000 people leave
every day and 50,000 new people come in
every day but there's have different
hours they're not getting in the way of
the nine-to-fivers the 90 percent are
yes we are when they go to their
auditions it's like people coming in LA
to be a lawyer like an accountant it's
like you could do that anywhere why they
died here to stay close to your family
it's all about family values people well
there's so many industries within the
entertainment it's true - like fashion
districts here so like if you want to be
like a costume designer or a fashion
person like that's here and then there's
also much cheaper dream fish editions
yeah everything's here different yeah if
you if you don't have dreams like why
bother working in LA you're just putting
yourself through hell how some people
just want to live the LA lifespan the
taxes are too damn high here never heard
of that people just move here because
they want the I'm like why do you dream
of LA why her thing is she says I moved
to LA from Lorna yeah she's like I moved
to LA I finally got to LA to not be one
of them well I thought your point I
Lauren oh the girl
here to work in entertainment or not a
wannabe though you're not a wannabe you
actually work in entertainment right I'm
talking about the rest of the people who
are lazy as [ __ ] and they want to appear
as a famous person that's hurt yeah they
they [ __ ] and then they go back and
they're like I'm tired of LA and they so
fake [ __ ] la you were the fake one
that was here being fake
yeah there's no yeah I don't know why
I've never heard of this la is a fake
city ever
another la I've never heard of that yeah
and then it's it's usually transplants
or people that come from LA chasing Fame
that create this like la is fake yeah le
has the most blunt realist [ __ ]
on earth the native Angelenos yeah yeah
but just people like that never run into
native Angelenos because angelitos are
out here at Monterey Park nothing that's
true real Angelenos don't live in
Hollywood yeah yeah all the places that
people wanna Alea yeah they want to live
the LA lifestyle not her pages back up a
lot of people are commenting like oh
your pages back up I'm gonna keep
reporting it yeah oh damn I'm like I
need to get a job did she get more
followers from this she actually did she
got one because before when her account
got deleted it was at 113 I heard that
song in the long time
I like that it's enough she's almost at
1:30 so she's going and she's probably
gonna get more from our viewers here
because we're very powerful and
influential I mean I would follow her to
laugh at her though no no I think
honestly I think that's why a lot of
people are following because I'm her
YouTube I looked at her channel and all
of her videos are so cringy where people
are like thank you for my daily dose of
cringe and like that's why they're
following man because she's yeah it's
like good trainers like you're watching
a trainer I take it back you don't have
to leave LA I like to know what I you
know like you feel that if you buy like
miserable people the gate chipper
I like music yeah I am you're here you
gotta be this ye shall not enter la she
reminds me of the Nicole Arbour oh yeah
oh I like her too I like but she's
actually like articulate at best things
just memorize that if you guys yeah she
knows how she titles buddy oh dear fat
people yeah yeah yeah I she was a part
of a scandal with the Malibu wine you
just know when there was a fire and they
were like they're like Stan Lee isn't
being saved she like went out there she
was like battling Whitney Cummings
who was like reporting that they were
not taking care of the draft she was
like if they are does last I didn't hurt
her did she beat up Matthew Santoro all
the time oh man really dating yeah yeah
no need a video crying saying like I
feel bad for a dude I like I like his
content I think he's awesome
[Music]